[Music]
making the modern multiverse review of
the number of the heavens a history of
the multiverse and the quest to
understand the cosmos by Tom Siegfried
Harvard University Press 2019 one of the
liveliest scientific debates is whether
our universe is unique
unlike some controversies the multiverse
debate is highly interdisciplinary
philosophers theologians and of course
businesses all cling to entrenched
positions about the multiverse is
reality perhaps no other topic than the
multiverse has so clearly and
passionately raised the question of what
constitutes science into this debate
comes the number of the heavens a
history of the multiverse and the quest
to understand the cosmos by Tom
Siegfried the former editor-in-chief of
science news an author of three books
including strange matters undiscovered
ideas at the frontiers of space and time
2002 despite his journalistic
credentials Siegfried is not a
dispassionate observer or turgid he
boldly asserts his opinions as he
enumerates the many ways humanity has
understood the multiverse from antiquity
to today combining interviews of modern
physicists and philosophers with
detailed historical narrative of ancient
Medieval and Renaissance interpretations
of the word world Siegfried's text
fields an important gap in the expanding
body of multiverse literature his
approach to the multiverse is liberal
possible universe have at times included
other planets in our solar system other
stars in our galaxy planets around other
stars in our galaxy other galaxies in
our universe and parallel universes in
both space and time
Siegfried thus gives the interpretation
of multiverse a wide berth however only
the parallel universes interpretation is
relevant to modern physicists the number
of the heavens is intended for a general
audience the book's first 2/3 is replete
with ancient conceptions of the
multiverse though clearly the ancient
thinkers were considering other possibly
habitable planets rather than multiple
universes nowadays no scientist or
philosopher doubts the existence of such
world's even earth-like ones
whereas the evidence from multiple
universes is it as yet non-existent
Siegfried sees the modern interpretation
of the multiverse as an inevitable
logical evolution of Copernican thought
why would our universe be singular 7
other planets aside from earth populate
our solar system alone a hundred or
billion or more Suns in the Milky Way
and a similar number of galaxies exist
in the observable universe Siegfried
writes about many historical scientists
Copernicus included who entertained the
notion that some version of the
multiverse may exist the historical
prologue though interesting takes up
most of the book that leaves only a few
chapters for Sigrid's juiciest prose on
the modern meaning of the multiverse
Everett many worlds theory and the
inflationary multiverse the imbalance
between ancient and modern multiverse
conceptions isn't the books only a short
company most notably the perspective of
multiverse opponents are only minimally
covered as an experimental cosmologists
working to constrain models of inflation
I was disappointed not to find a
description of the most promising
approach to discovering evidence for
inflation and potentially the no divers
as well B mode polarization of the
Cosmic Microwave Background siegfried
reject science philosopher Karl poppers
idea that the demarcation between
scientific and unscientific theories
lies in the ability to be proven false
but Siegfried provides know all their
alternative rather he cites the opinions
of Stephen Weinberg Leonard Susskind
John Carroll Lisa Randall another mode
of multiverse proponents or he asserts
his own opinions
his referring to opponents of the
multiverse with the pejorative deniers
lengths them with deniers of evolution
climate change or worse a less partisan
presentation would have improved the
books balance funding multiverse
opponents is not exactly difficult and
informative if heated debate recently
took place between multiverse proponents
and opponents in reaction to the article
by M aegis Paul Steinhardt and Avraham
Loeb in the February 2017 issue of
Scientific American healthy debate is a
welcome feature of the
first landscape other books on the
multiverse include Brian Greene's the
hidden reality parallel universes of the
deep laws of the cosmos and Max tegmark
s-- our mathematical universe my quest
for the ultimate nature of reality those
texts largely eschew the history of the
multiverse can cover the pertinent if
esoteric physics more thoroughly the
number of the heavens shines when
Siegfried adopts a journalistic
neutrality about the arguments for and
against the multiverse his wry wit is
evident throughout but nowhere more so
than when relating past episodes of
confusing and even contradictory
interpretation of metaphysical ideas at
the outset siegfried stresses that there
is no greater story in science than the
human quest to comprehend the cosmos our
understanding of the universe is rapidly
expanding but physicists still debate
the definition of the words we use to
describe the cosmos as capacious
nosotras constantly evolves at least
with the number of the heavens we
finally know begin
[Music]
[Music]